you have to understand like it's so
funny I I live
and I live and breathe you because like
Manu nalo yeah has been our show water
since we launched
there and it is and you you were the
first which is really cool cuz in F like
everyone followed suit after you you you
were our first and when you were on the
Hawaiian Airlines like giving out Manalo
I just was like that that just made me
so joyful and so happy like you are that
person I mean like you are like the real
life Aquaman I I know you hear that all
the time but like when Aquaman came your
way were you like oh well yeah this
works
I I get this well at first I was a bit
in shocked because you know you picture
him a different way and then until Zach
was like no he should be Polynesian it
makes sense and I'm like oh my God it
makes total sense to be to be half
Polynesian and half atlantan but then at
the root of it my passion my whole life
has been I wanted to be a myologist and
I'm completely obsessed with everything
that's in the ocean so and and just an
activist for the environment in general
so when you become Aquaman it just kind
of put me on a platform where I never
had like little kids looking up to me
and I didn't have you know generally the
roles I played were pretty vicious and
not really me but my heart is in this
the kids want Aquaman and other people
like you know they're like Drogo and
other things oh my God I am sitting with
car Drogo no tell me everything what was
it like I mean oh my God Cal Drogo it's
a decade ago it's been a while it's been
well it's ever present in all of our
minds um and I I don't know who I was
more excited by you or kisi and then
when the two of you came together I was
like well this is everything I've ever
lived for right here in front of me me
was was that fun yeah she's amazing I
mean the whole show is amazing yeah it
was a wonderful time in my life and
you're very big on loin cloths you know
you wear one in real life and then
you're wearing like a suede lo you you
like to be in loin cloths which we all
like too I'm not a big fan of clothes
yeah like we didn't Hawaiian aren't you
know we didn't wear too much so that's a
good thing
yeah I run hot you do I do I I'm I'm a
I'm a yeah I'm a furnace I I run cold
actually really yeah I'm freezing all
the time yeah we're opposite on that end
no that's okay cuz you know I grew up in
California and so the very first place I
actually wrote a chapter in my book
called Wildflower and there's a chapter
called The Royal Hawaiian um about the
hotel and my very first place I ever
traveled to um outside of California was
Hawaii and I fell in love with that so
that's where I'm going to stay and when
you watch Aquaman I wear the pink robe
and it says the Royal Hawai so in the
opening of I wear the pink robe all the
time as Aquaman so when you see the
trail like it's in the trailer you see
me like pull off clothes on the line but
I'm in a pink Roe yes of course I
watched it last night that's the Royal
Hawaiian that's where I stay too so it's
wonderful I'll be staying there and War
Brothers has been amazing in DC they're
going to show the movie before it comes
out um I haven't really I haven't really
announced it yet but we're going to go
to Hawaii and I think we're going to try
to do three days two to three days of
showing people in Maui who lost their
homes and be able to like just give it
to the community and let them go to the
theaters and they'll be free and then
we're going to do one on aaho too I'll
come and see my
[Music]
family